hi I'm rich Briggs brand director at
Crystal Dynamics and I'm excited to show
you the new content were bringing to
rise of the Tomb Raider 20-year
celebration including an exclusive sneak
peek at our new Blood Ties story in rise
of the Tomb Raider Lara uncovers an
ancient mystery that places are in the
crosshairs of a ruthless organization
known as Trinity as she races to find
the secret before them the trail leads
to a myth about the lost city of Kadesh
Lara knows she must reached the lost
city and its hidden secrets before
Trinity so she sets out for Siberia on
her first tomb raiding expedition woman
versus wild is our evolution of survival
action in which Lara battles not only
enemies but the world itself you'll hunt
animals to craft weapons and scavenge
for rare resources in a densely
populated ecosystem you'll encounter
beautifully hostile environment full of
treacherous conditions and unstable
landscapes that will require Lara to
push her limits to the very edge this
includes the new guerrilla combat
tactics where you'll use the environment
to your advantage
scaling trees and diving under water to
avoid or take down enemies and
configuring Lara's gear weapons and ammo
to suit your playstyle from stealth to
guns blazing craft explosives on the fly
to sow chaos and wield Lara's signature
combat bows and climbing axe tombs are
back and they're bigger and better than
ever you'll explore huge inspiring
ancient space is littered with deadly
traps dramatic environmental puzzles and
decipher ancient text to reveal crypts
as you take on a world filled with
secrets to discover
2016 marks the 20th anniversary of the
first Tomb Raider game and we knew we
had to do something special to celebrate
Lara Croft and the impact she's made on
the entertainment industry first we
wanted this to be the most comprehensive
version of the game possible so we
bundled all of the previously released
DLC including the critically acclaimed
baba-yaga single-player story cold
darkness awakening and endurance mode
which you can now play with a friend as
you raid tombs and the frozen Siberian
wilderness together we've created a new
outfit inspired by Tomb Raider 3 as well
as five classic Lara skins it looks
pretty amazing to see the low-poly skins
alongside the beautifully detailed world
and characters of rise of the Tomb
Raider it's a walk down memory lane and
that's just the beginning
we knew that the Manor would be a great
place to explore in Lara's modern
timeline it's such an important part of
Lara's rise and it represents her home
her base her fortune and her legacy
in the new Blood Ties story ownership of
the manor is being contested by Lara's
uncle and she has to explore the estate
for proof that she's the rightful heir
or lose the manor for good lara
experiences flashbacks and collect
documents and journals and relics for
additional backstory on her early years
Lara will discover her father's vault of
knowledge where he was compiling ancient
truths that he kept secret even from her
however we wanted to be sure we had some
action in combat as well which brings us
to Lara's nightmare this is a special
mode in which the manor has been overrun
by zombies there's a psychological
aspect to this because Lara is battling
her inner demons to retain ownership of
her childhood home she'll need to
overcome hordes of infectious zombies as
well as boss battles in order to reclaim
her birthright we're excited about the
upcoming launch of rise of the Tomb
Raider 20 year celebration on October 11
Blood Ties adds over an hour of
completely new story content to an
already robust experience pushing the
total gameplay above 50 hours
in the next episode we'll give you an
inside look at how blood ties can be
experienced in an all-new interactive
virtual reality mode on PlayStation 4
you'll be able to play the world through
Lara's eyes for the first time in
franchise history
thanks for watching
you